new tonight the clark county education
association has filed a formal ethics
complaint
against clark county school board
trustee lisa guzman
this is due to an apparent conflict of
interest with her current employment and
other relations
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
joins us tonight now with the details
madison yes her current employment with
the nevada state education association
and former affiliation
with the education support employees
association is what's causing the stir
ccea sent a strongly worded letter to
the board of trustees
about their concerns earlier this month
that includes questioning if guzman's
association with the competing teachers
union
potentially making it a problem to be
impartial
in any matters regarding ccea the union
asked guzman to resign from her position
or recuse herself from all votes
involving unions that work with the
school district
guzman who was in thursday night's
school board meeting
abstained from the vote between ccea and
ccsd
about the teachers returning to schools
and offered board members this reason
i just wanted to let everyone know that
i
am going to be abstaining from this vote
due to my
awaiting the ethics advisory commission
determination so i just wanted to let
people know so they know why i'm not
asking questions and i'm not going to be
voting
the teachers union announced the ethics
complaint on twitter
this morning and eight news now received
a comment from guzman earlier today
stating that all she wants to do is to
make sure that the district remains
focused
on planning for a safe reopening and
that all educators get vaccinated safely
reporting in studio madison kimbrough 8
news now